we each have our little differences but
we come out
being friends in the end saved by the
bells dustin diamond
has been hospitalized et has confirmed
the 44 year old actor sought medical
attention
over the weekend in florida dustin's
team tells e.t he's quote
undergoing tests to determine the source
of various body pains he had been
experiencing dustin will undergo a
biopsy
and his doctors have noted they're
concerned it could be a yet
unknown form of cancer his team said
right now they're just asking people to
put him
in their thoughts and prayers
i need to borrow your brain no way zack
you still haven't returned my tricycle
from kindergarten
dustin is most well known for playing
screech
on save by the bell
are those caffeine pills dustin was not
part of the recent reimagining
of the hit sitcom on peacock and his
former co-star
elizabeth berkley told et she wasn't
sure if he would appear on the show
if it gets renewed you know i know
there's a complicated history with
dustin diamond but he's been so public
about really wanting to be a part of it
you're a producer on the show what is it
gonna take to maybe see him in season
two
if there's a season two you know what
well from your mouth right
hopefully there's a season two um you
know what i'm
one of a whole group of great producers
and
i mean dustin listen i don't know
we're discussing but i just don't know
yet it depends on the story lines and
how they play out
and all of that but i i wish
dustin nothing but the best um i just
haven't seen him for
a lot of years but i do wish him the
best he was always kind to me